ladies and gentlemen of the jury
[Music]
how y'all doing all y'all that don't
know who I am my name is Willie Gary
Willie Gary Willie William Gary never
heard of him what's so special about
this guy anyway
[Music]
S I never got myself into a lot of
trouble I've been your lawyer 30 years
we can find a way out of it you've never
sued anybody before in your whole life
I'm just going to try to bully me out of
business and I don't think I should be
expected to stand for it Mr Gary hasn't
lost a case in over 12 years you
suggesting I hire this guy's one of my
lawyers y'all come on in pleasure to
meet you Mr Gary let me introduce you to
my call Red how do you feel about
working with black folk I suppose I am a
little Prejudice did you meet my team
I'm Chris it's a shot Tracy Douglas
gentlemen he's suing us he's suing us we
are a half a billion dollar cooperation
so how much money y'all trying to get
eight million that ain't enough money
100 million dollars
who is this clown he's hired as a lawyer
your fighter man what made you want to
do it because he tried to mess with the
one thing that means the most to me in
life being able to leave something
behind for my grandchildren
my name is Maine Downs graduated top of
her class from Harvard Law School they
had a nickname for her around the office
the python I wouldn't get too used to me
being kind to you Mr Gary once we begin
that trial I want to destroy you
can't you see that we're golden we only
have a snowball's chance in hell of
winning this case just just trust me
okay I I may have found something what
does it feel like to be some small time
nobody on the verge of bankruptcy
you have been trying to turn this into
your own one ringing circus I got my
damn life on the line I know that Jerry
did it ever bother you democracy the
hypocrisy
your honor Ed
I can't split the pole okay
we're golden